[Musique]
et avant mai prochain invité il m'a
rejoint également plateau c'est michael
et demi d'euros - servez gorille pour la
chronique sports du lundi c'est la
dernière de cette saison et oui ça joue
vite
alors pour cette dernière vous allez
nous proposer des tops et des flops de
la saison sportive dans le département
et oui et on commence par les flops et
et oui il ya eu quelques déceptions dans
les yvelines j'insiste bien sur
déception dans ses flops on retrouve des
équipes oudéa sportif qui on aurait aimé
voir au plus haut niveau
en football américain pressenti pour
aller en d1 les templiers d'elancourt ne
monteront pas cette année favori la
rencontre ils se sont inclinés en
play-off de 2e division les élans
pourtant été battu par les gladiateurs
de la queue en brie en demi-finale de
conférence 15 alice et s'incline à ce
niveau pour la deuxième année
consécutive une vraie déception pour le
club qui végète rats en deuxième
division pour la quatrième année
consécutive le continu sur les flops
avec de la boxe alors notre deuxième
flop concerne donc la boxe et puis
particulièrement à marvin petit l'élan
courtois a perdu pour la deuxième fois
de sa carrière le boxer surnommé le
gitan s'est incliné aux points à face
aux belges francesco patera en février
dernier en belgique
il ne deviendra donc pas champion ebu
européen des poids légers cette année
depuis marvin petit n'est pas remonté
sur un ring alors troisième flotte
future a3 flop trois tops cette séquence
flop avec du handball nikam on va
prendre direction plaisir plaisir qu'il
n'a pas à réussi à réaliser une bonne
saison en nationale 3 le plaisir oies
qui avait accédé à ses divisions en 2017
ont connu une année compliquée les
joueurs de victor garrigues et l'a
emporté que six victoires en vente 22
matches disputés des résultats qui
n'aurait pas été suffisant sur le paquet
pour se maintenir le club termine 10ème
sur 12 mais réussit tout de même à se
maintenir in extremis dans la division
suite un repêchage une mesure qui va
permettre à plaisir de conserver ses
meilleurs éléments et surtout ces jeunes
hors pack des flops il y aussi des
touches positive cette saison forcément
des tops
on commence par du rugby le club des
versets connu une saison extraordinaire
les joueurs de la cité royale ont été
invaincus cette saison ils ont emporté
largement tous les matches de phase de
poules ils ont emporté le titre de
champion ile de france en s'imposant
contre vincennes en finale et
performances qui vont leur permettre de
monter en fédérale 3 l'année prochaine
seul bémol les verse ayant perdu contre
vesoul aux tirs au but en championnat de
france deuxième top c'est un événement
international auquel vous avez participé
le golfe
en tant que journaliste qui a exactement
le golfe et l'organisation de la ryder
cup 2018 la compétition était organisée
au golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines en septembre dernier
l'événement a réuni sur les greens les
plus grandes stars internationales de la
discipline comme tiger woods ou rory
mcilroy dans les tribunes 270 mille
personnes sont venues assister à la
compétition
et puis d'un milliard de personnes ont
regardé à la télé on regarde à la
télévision la compétition était
tellement réussie que des rumeurs sur
une nouvelle candidature du golf
national de circulent mais on termine
par quoi nickel mon dernier top concerne
l'équipe de baseball des cougars de
montigny le bretonneux lésigny montant
terminé finaliste de première division
en septembre dernier
pour cette nouvelle saison ils ont
réussi à terminer troisième qu'une coupe
d'europe pour la première fois de leur
histoire
même s'il n'arriveront pas être
finaliste cette saison en championnat
l'année est déjà réussie pour les
cougars
merci michael on vous retrouve dans le
cetud sport dans un instant où vous
ferez un bilan de la saison c'est sa
sportive dans le département exactement
je m'échauffais injustement